i'm
a very strong person and i'm not just
talking like muscles
i'm i'm a very stubborn person
and stubborn is a really good word for
me because i just don't give up and i
love when someone tells me
oh you can't do that oh really watch me
[Music]
so when i was eight years old i was
diagnosed with viewing sarcoma which is
a rare form of bone cancer
they decided they were going to give me
chemotherapy for two years and amputate
my leg from the knee down
i've been an amputee for 29 years
i work out five days a week
kind of a typical day for me would be
me getting up really early
get up at 3 45 in the morning
i head over to the gym
i get about an hour workout and then
whenever i get home
i'm making breakfast making my husband's
lunch getting my husband out the door
which can be a task some days sometimes
i hit the gym a second time
i'm up to refuge barbell which is my
strongman gym
every person i've ever met in strongman
is absolutely
mental but you know this community is
great
and then being able to spend time with
my girls
i'm raising two girls who will
understand
what it's like for someone with a
different ability level
to be them
[Music]
when i was a kid it was a lot harder to
be an amputee growing up i had a lot of
body issues because
i didn't look like everyone else when
someone doesn't understand something
they tend to
fear it and we all go through it
some of us just go through it a little
harder because we're dealing with
something
extra you never know we're all going
through something
our two daughters and they see me doing
all this stuff
and you know lifting heavy weights and
cycling
and running and they get to see me doing
that
they're not going to put any
misconceptions on someone else and i
think that's awesome
[Music]
uh do you think that do you think that
you're at a disadvantage
yeah sure but we all are
i want to see what my body can do why
not
and i want to push the limits
putting limitations on someone before
you can see what they're really capable
of
is denying that person of becoming
stronger and so i want those individuals
that are watching to realize like
we're all absolutely abled
we just have different ways of doing it
that's it
[Music]
so
[Music]
you